hey Vsauce Michael here and when the
Pyramids of Giza were built the tallest
was 147 meters tall making them the
tallest things humans had ever built and
they remained that way for nearly four
thousand years it wasn't even until the
1300s that we finally got around to
making something taller a Cathedral in
England so does that mean that the Great
Pyramids of Giza are the best tallest
structures of all time well find out
more all aboard the boat so what is a
building well technically a building is
a structure in which at least 50% of its
height comes from floor plates where
people can live work
chill out it has to be habitable any
less than that and it's not a building
it's a tower after the lincoln cathedral
finally surpassed the height of the
pyramids a number of churches continue
to be built that kept breaking and
setting new records the next long term
record holder was the Eiffel Tower it
was the tallest thing ever in history
that we had built for about 40 years in
a row it was finally surpassed by the
Chrysler Building in New York a personal
favorite which was then quickly bested
by the Empire State Building now the
Empire State Building is interesting in
that it was the first structure ever
built by a man that was so tall were you
to jump off the top of it you would
actually reach terminal velocity before
he hit the bottom it was the first
structure we'd ever built that was so
tall rather than just continuing to
accelerate as you fell you would
actually stop accelerating because you
would reach the fastest possible speed
your limp body can fall out
in the mid-1950s something weird started
to happen humans started to build radio
and TV towers these things could be way
taller than the buildings that we've
made previously that had to be habitable
and so ever since the Empire State
Building had its record broken by a TV
tower all these other famously tall
buildings the Petronas Towers Taipei 101
the World Trade Center the Willis Tower
formerly Sears Tower none of them have
ever within their existence actually
held the title for being the tallest
thing we've ever built there was always
a radio or TV tower somewhere that we
Stallard up until quite recently and for
quite a while
the record for the tallest thing ever
built by humans went to the Warsaw radio
mast in Poland it's visually incredibly
striking because there aren't any other
skyscrapers around it it's all alone
being very tall well that was until 1991
where some workers exchanging guy wires
made a mistake and the whole thing
started to bend and then snapped in the
middle there's no video of the event
happening but it would have been similar
to this collapse though much much taller
[Applause]
after the Warsaw radio mast collapsed
the KVLY TV mast in North Dakota became
the tallest still standing structure
built by me but recently buildings have
made a comeback and to check that out
we're gonna have to travel to the Middle
East this is the first time I've ever
touched the Nile
[Music]
but uh okay so that was me dipping my
waterproof camera into the Nile if you
were to take the entire length of the
Nile River and stand it up on its edge
perpendicular to the earth it would
reach into outer space about this far
it's pretty impressive but where does
the Space Shuttle orbit and where does
the International Space Station orbit
this far away this far away maybe this
far away actually if this pink
inflatable Horrible Bosses ball was the
earth the Space Shuttle would orbit
about right there it's incredible but
it's possible because the shuttle and
the International Space Station travels
so quickly they travel so quickly around
the Earth that instead of seeing one
sunrise and sunset every 24 hours
they see 16 but don't be jealous you can
easily see more than one sunrise and/or
sunset in a day by taking advantage of
tall structures so let's take a look at
the tallest structure the current
record-holder for the tallest thing
humans have ever built the Burj Khalifa
in Dubai the height of this building
blows my mind you can literally watch
the sunset from the base of the building
and then take a super-fast elevator all
the way up to the top and watch the same
Sun set again in fact the difference in
timing between sunset at the base and
the top is so significant
the Dubai Islamic Affairs Department
actually had to make a ruling about wind
you can start and break here fast during
Ramadan inside the building people above
floor 80 or higher have to actually wait
to start eating 2 to 3 minutes after the
people at the base because the Sun
hasn't yet set
for those at the top but before you head
to Dubai to watch the Sun rise or set
twice in a day keep in mind that the
only hype you actually need to see two
sunrises or sunsets is the height of
your own body try this the next time
you're at a beach watch the Sun rise or
set over the water water is important
because it won't have the terrain and
Hill issues that land does now let's say
you're watching a sunset begin by laying
on your stomach watch the sunset and as
soon as the very last little bit of the
Sun goes below the horizon quickly pop
up into a standing position and voila
you'll see the sun's back part of its
back and it will set another time if you
take a stopwatch and record the time
between the first setting and the second
setting that you witness and measure the
height of your eyes when you're laying
down and when you're standing you can
use those numbers to calculate the
radius of the earth xkcd took this a
little bit further by proposing the
double sunset date take your date out to
the beach in a cherry picker and sure
enough it was calculated given the speed
of a cherry picker all you have to do is
move about six feet up and you can watch
a beautiful sunset all over again
to put things in perspective the Burj
Khalifa is nowhere near as tall as Mount
Everest but the tallest structure that
we could potentially build wouldn't be
as tall as Mount Everest it would be way
way taller like in this face taller of
course the problem with building things
that are really tall is that they get
heavier and heavier and have to support
their own weight but only up to a point
if a structure was so tall that it wound
up at the altitude of a geostationary
orbit it would start to feel a new force
not just a gravitational force downward
but all of a sudden this new centrifugal
force up and outward and so a building
that tall could be
stable through tension and more than
35,000 kilometers high this kind of
structure is known as a space elevator
unfortunately there aren't any materials
known to science today that are strong
enough to make building something that
large feasible with the exception maybe
of carbon nanotubes or boron nitride
nanotubes of course if we went to a
smaller celestial body like the moon we
could build one today out of stuff like
Kevlar there are a lot of different
things that we have to be wary of when
we build a space elevator for instance
how do we dodge space debris one
solution is to attach the earth side of
the cable to a boat in the ocean that
can maneuver around and move the
elevator away from dangerous obstacles
another interesting point is that the
taller the cable the faster the far end
of it will be traveling in fact if the
cable is more than 50 thousand
kilometers long its far end will be
traveling near escape velocity and
simply walking outside could take you to
the moon but why build a space elevator
well because it would be awesome but
also for better reasons - for instance
right now in order to send a pound of
material into orbit it costs about
eleven thousand dollars but with a space
elevator we could send the same amount
of material into orbit for only about a
hundred bucks that difference is so
significant that philip reagan has said
that the first country to deploy a space
elevator will have a ninety five percent
cost advantage and will possibly be able
to control all space related activities
alright so here you see in the mirror
Alex playing guitar while she holds the
camera in her mouth and records us
impressive I'm here with Kristin from
barely political she's visiting London
and if you enjoyed this episode of boat
check out other episodes I've got them
all up there and as always thanks for
watching oh and check out Kristin's
Channel right there
I bye